قطعت أحكام نادية التي يتردد صداها
مع الصدمة التي نجت من داعش
في سنجار على الرغم من أنها نجت من مصير
رفاقها الإيزيديين من العبيد الجنسيين فقط
لتجد نفسها محاصرة في كابوس مماثل
تقول إنها جاءت إلى بغداد مع
رجل تثق به وأخبرها أنه يعرفه.  عضوة في
البرلمان يمكنها مساعدة أسرتها في التقدم بطلب للحصول على
اللجوء في الولايات المتحدة في يوم خريفي يأكلون فيه
بمفردهم ويلتزمون بمساعدتهم
معظمهم يتأخرون لشهور
تقول إنها كانت تسجن في غرفة
كل ليلة تقول إنهم سيعطونها
حقنة كل ليلة  في الصباح كانت
تستيقظ عارية محاطة
بزجاجات كحول فارغة وتتألم من ألم
العديد من الرجال يغتصبونها ، مرحبًا جانا ديليا
هي السفينة الأم العظمية رجلك.
لقد أحضر خاطفوها امرأة
أخرى للاعتناء بها ، واحدة أخرى من
ضحاياهم تجلس في مدينة في إيطاليا ، نحن
نظيفون ، ونحن بشأن فكرتنا.
شارلوت من أجل التكريم الدجال المطلوب ،
لا ثنائية نيفا غالا
لقائمة الطعام ، حصلت مارلين على جلالة الملك ،
وتزدهرت تجارة دنيئة منظمة بشكل غير محكم تزدهر في
العراق التي تصل مخالبها إلى
الحكومة العراقية أهدافها الفئات الضعيفة
اليائسة التي نزحت من قبل داعش
والقتال الذي أعقب ذلك
إنها تكذب المشاهد النابضة بالحياة في
العاصمة العراقية أولئك الذين تحدثنا إليهم غير مدركين
لحجم الأزمة أو وصمة العار
والخوف من الانتقام يسكت
غالبية الضحايا بالطبع د.
يقول علي أكرم البياتي ، وهو عضو
في لجنة مكافحة الاتجار بالبشر
الحكومية ، إنهم لا يستطيعون فعل الكثير
بخلاف التحدث إلى وسائل الإعلام إذا كنت
تتحدث عن الاتجار بالبشر
بالطبع عندما تحقق سترى
بعض المسؤولين الذين نعمل
معهم.  لتسميتهم سيكون من غير المجدي
أنهم أقوياء للغاية ، كما يقول ، أولئك الذين
يمكن أن يحاسبوهم مثل عمولته الخاصة
ضعيفة للغاية ، ومن ثم
هناك تهديدات مستمرة.
من
منظمتك غير الحكومية سر
ولا يزال هناك الكثير من الخوف حول
كل شيء لماذا تقول إنه
بسبب تهديدات القتل من المافيا
والميليشيات صوت الحملان يهز
جسمها النحيف يرتجف تحت القماش الأسود
الذي ترتديه لإخفاء هويتها
منهج يوتيوب أوه نعم البطلينوس  كانت
فريسة سهلة للمتجرين بالبشر الذين يتجولون في
شوارع بغداد فقدوا خائفين غارقة في مثل هذه
المدينة الكبيرة المزدحمة
التي لم ترَ مثلها في حياتها.  في إحدى المقاطعات
، استقبلت سيارة أجرة ولكن لم يكن لديها أي فكرة عن المكان
الذي ستذهب إليه ، فقد نقلت قصتها
للسائق وأخبرته كيف هربت من
المنزل أن شقيقها الأكبر كان من داعش
أمير الذي ضربها وحبسها
وهددها بالقتل بعد أن قامت بقتلها.
تحدث سائق التاكسي الذي عرض عليه المساعدة في الحصول
على الفتيات على ماشا كاتي الطبي
لاسا مولي بشار بعد الآن في
العقي Upadhyaya جوني ، أخذها إلى
منزل امرأة حيث وعدها
بأن تكون رجلًا آمنًا في حالة حب مع Ben في
مكان قريب ، أعني كنت هناك  سونيا أرماند
غدًا ليس للأدب ، آمل أن
يحصلوا على الشاي الخاص بي ، ستحاول الطاقة
الأرخص مع القليل من الدعم ولا توجد
عدالة فقط مع آلامها
توقف العديد من الأشخاص غير المعروفين الذين لم
يجيبوا هل كنت تعرف SSR في ميني لي أي شخص
أحتاجه  قال رأسك من أسفل كنت
أنا شياطيننا بغداد